[Musique]
un jour comme les l'après-midi ménagères
s'achève
il va bientôt rentrer elle sera belle
pour lui en ce moment il doit déjà avoir
quitté le bureau pour le volant de leur
petite auto oui évidemment almaty vous
ne pouvez pas imaginez monsieur qu'il en
soit autrement et il vous paraît naturel
quel meuble cette attente en se parant
pour vous mais elle vous êtes vous
demandez à quoi elle pensait en ce jour
anniversaire de mariage ils vous voient
très bien courant vers le premier
fleurissent et bien nous c'est plus sain
vous n'aviez plus de sia
[Musique]
d'ailleurs vous avez bien d'autres
soucis une journée bureau les roannais
de l'aube tard le téléphone qui sonne
sans arrêt la crise de foi du directeur
et cette circulation et ses feux rouges
et ses agents qui ne sont pas compris
[Musique]
vivement le calme du foyer
tu permets de seconde je suis en train
de faire le journal était sans doute
parce que maintenant
excuse moi par exemple je suis en train
de lire le journal
je rentre du travail je suis fatigué et
on a envie conduite la balle très tôt
[Musique]
écoute c'est le gars de faux qu'il faut
le payer également l'assurance quoi tu
veux dire l'assurance vie seulement rien
à faire mais seulement huit mois je suis
en très bonne santé
ça va très bien je suis simplement
fatigué d'attendre un petit peu pour
porter la durée en pis moi je n'étais
pas moi tu pourrais être occupé de notre
avenir des enfants par exemple je
m'occupe des enfants parce que j'ai
travaillé toute la journée c'est hulk
parents pour les enfants
mais si je suis fatigué ce soir et il se
peut qu'on foute la paix c'est justement
à cause des enfants et toi comment
celui-ci l'a prise
commenge supportable oui l'école tablier
déchiré en finlande est là pourquoi
pourquoi je suis pas là à y voir
nettoyer la terre des enfants
alors à vous de ce que tu veux tu es
journées croyable je travaillerai je
rentrerai chez moi on n'aurait rien à me
dit ce serait parfait mcsherry mais
repose toi je t'en prie mais à la maison
non non à la maison je ne fais rien et
bien non cela ne va pas du tout et nous
préférons arrêté à temps cette soirée
irrémédiablement gâchée
dès le départ c'est justement le départ
qui est mort
et voyez vous il suffit de très peu de
choses pour que les événements speed un
tout autre
alors si vous voulez bien nous allons
tout recommence et vous allez prendre un
bon départ
j
alors ça va bien passé aujourd'hui dans
une grosse comme toujours en france
c'est bien dans sa toile aussi gentil
les enfants mais ça je dis donc je
voulais demander où on se sentait un peu
crispé je connais pas grand chose dans
ce choix
tu peux être cette fois c'est un lourd
sac de rome qui me crispait nouveau
baigneurs il sait rien du tout le garçon
bien
bon tout ça est récitée bon et virages
secs de malchance j'ai pensé à voile et
dix diacres l impôt les impôts les
impôts lui est bon les payeurs de moi tu
vois c'est la rangée on ne sait pas
merveilleux qui sciemment des soins très
simple vous jugez pas mi-temps
aujourd'hui j'avais le temps tu es
beaucoup de choses à faire je pensais
que
peut-être aller restaurant ce soir on
s'émerveille tu sais pas ce que je
pensais au boulot cet après midi il ya
longtemps que j'ai pas emmener monique
dauré store eh ben on va y aller et un
jour comme les l'après-midi ménagères sa
sève
il va bientôt rentrer elle sera belle
pour lui en ce moment il doit déjà avoir
quitté le bureau pour le volant de leur
petite auto oui évidemment elle maladie
vous ne pouvez pas imaginez monsieur
qu'il en soit autrement et il vous
paraît naturel quel meuble cet attentant
se parent pauvre mais elle vous êtes
vous demandez à quoi elle pensait en ce
jour anniversaire de mariage ils vous
voient très bien courant vers le pommier
fleurissent et bien nous c'est plus
simple vous n'aviez plus de cigarettes
[Musique]
à
d'ailleurs vous avez bien d'autres
soucis
une journée de bureau les rendez-vous en
retard le téléphone qui sonne sans arrêt
la crise de foi du directeur
et cette circulation wc feux rouges et
ses agents qui ne sont pas compréhensifs
[Musique]
en mouvement le calme du foyer
techniquement tout tu perds mes deux
secondes je suis en train de faire le
journal était très vite parler ça
maintenant excuse moi parler par exemple
le gard je suis en train de lire le
journal
je rentre du travail je suis fatigué
j'ai envie qu'on puisse la paille c'est
tout écoute non pas tant par les petits
de l'assurance maladie
il faut qu'il faut le beagle également
l'assurance quoi tu me dire assurance
vie selon lui mais rien à faire valoir
moi je le suis en très bonne santé ça va
très bien je suis simplement indiqué
s'attendre à un petit peu probantes et
l'assurance vie enfin je ne sais pas moi
tu pourrais être occupé de notre avenir
des enfants pas maintenant je m'occupe
des enfants parce que je vais travailler
toute la journée c'est justement pour
les enfants mais je suis fatigué ce soit
il se peut qu'on me foute la paix c'est
justement à cause des enfants est toi
qui l'a prise comment supporter
oui entre l'école tablier déchiré en
finlande est là pourquoi je suis là je
vais pas là pour nettoyer de la sphère
des enfants apavou était là et elle a
rappelé que tu veux tu es journées c'est
quand le croyable je travaillerai je
rentrerai chez moi on n'aurait rien à me
dire ce serait parfait mais je vais me
repose toi je t'en prie mais à la maison
non non à la maison je ne fais rien et
bien non cela ne va pas du tout et nous
préférons arrêté à temps cette foire est
irrémédiablement gâchée
dès le départ c'est justement le départ
qui est mort et voyez vous il suffit de
très peu de choses pour que les
événements speed un tout autre
alors si vous voulez bien nous allons
tous comment et vous allez prendre un
bon départ
j
alors ça va bien s'est bien passé
aujourd'hui dans une rose toujours ans
du bien dans sa toile des gentils les
enfants sur 10 h 10 dans soul et de
demander pardon
on se sentait un peu crispé quelques
fuites future maman je t'aime pas grand
chose d'autre chose qui pourrait être
lourde à travers un petit peu crispé aux
baigneurs ne faisait rien du tout ça le
garçon bien bon et précités valent en
virages secs de mal ça me fait penser à
moi avait dit yann l impôt les impôts
les abruzzes est bon les payera demain
tu vois c'est arrangé ils n'étaient pas
merveilleux qu'est ce qui allonge et
soir devant ses juges et pas du tout
aujourd'hui jamais le temps j'ai eu
beaucoup de choses à faire je pensais
que
peut-être avez restaurant ce soir on
s'émerveille et puis c'est parce que je
pensais au boulot cet après midi il ya
longtemps que j'ai pas emmener monique
dauré store est bon on va y aller
[Musique]